appelez juste une minute à une demi-minute
trois jours à moins que vous n'entendiez de moi
différent nous avons affaire à l'
équipe du format crash & bash pour la première fois se faire voler
pas d'amusement droit
crimes majeurs diriger l'
enquête affaire belmonts avec Chris
j'ai vu pouvons-nous parler  à propos de ce projet de loi non je
n'étais pas sûr que tu puisses le faire nous n'avons
pas fini Michael ce n'était pas
rempli j'ai dû convaincre ma sœur de
t'épargner il
y a un autre travail elle a dit qu'elle tue
chacun d'entre nous nous ne comprenons pas ça
chose
Poorman crew si le gars de l'aéroport nous avons un moyen
de faire en sorte que cela se produise, nous pourrions tirer à 999
triple 9 qu'est-ce que c'est ouais cela signifie que les
flics ont été tués chaque flic de la ville
court vers cet appel nous aurions toute la [ __ ] de
journée d'
accord je  Je suis bon, est-ce que quelqu'un
croit peut-être quelque chose de très gros, il est
sur le point de descendre,
il doit y avoir une autre façon
n'a pas de problème à sortir un flic Je fais un
flic comme
ton travail monstre le monstre
pas de limite à ce que les hommes désespérés  fera l'affaire
lorsqu'il sera poussé vers le bas